die bevölkerung reagiert sehr sehr
positiv auf den einsatz hier wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass assistenzeinsätze
an der staatsgrenze des bundesheeres
hier schon im burgenland tradition haben
wir haben einen assistenzeinsatz zur
grenzüberwachung würde davon 21 jahren
gehabt von 1990 beginnend damals im
zusammenhang mit dem fall des eisernen
vorhang ist und da hat bereits die
bevölkerung verstanden und auch gemerkt
und auch de facto gefüllt welche welchen
sicherheitsfaktor das bundesheer für die
bevölkerung aber für das land in summe
ausmachen kann und demzufolge war die
bevölkerung uns emotional sehr sehr nahe
hat uns die anerkennung und
wertschätzung in vielfacher hinsicht
immer wieder unter beweis gestellt und
das gilt es noch gilt bis jetzt wir
befinden uns jetzt derzeit in anderer
das ist im bezirk neusiedl im burgenland
unmittelbar hinter mir ist die
staatsgrenze zu ungarn und andauernd die
brücke von anderer ist bekannt dafür
dass es das tor der freiheit im zuge des
aufstandes 1956 war
als am 23 oktober als studentenunruhen
in budapest begonnen hatte entwickelte
sich nach wenigen tagen zu einem
regelrechten volksaufstand gegen das
kommunistische regime und die
besatzungsmacht der sowjetunion
der neu ernannte ungarische
ministerpräsident inneren arts versuchte
die rote armee zum abzug aus umgang zu
bewegen
und das schien ihm vorerst auch zu
gelingen niemand konnte ahnen dass das
lediglich der vorbereitung für einen
massiven militärischen gegenschlag
dienen sollte und als die ungarische
regierung ihre neutralität erklärung
abgab und damit auch den austritt aus
dem warschauer pakt kam es am vierten
november zu einem massiven einsatz
sowjetische truppen vor allem in
budapest und nach wenigen tagen war der
ungarische volksaufstand
niedergeschlagen und das kommunistische
regime wieder etabliert
bereits am 24 oktober 1956 verlegte das
österreichische bundesheer erste truppen
und verbände an die staatsgrenze unter
den soldaten war noch sehr viele
grundwehrdiener die gerade wenige tage
zuvor als erster eindruck uns termin der
jungen republik zu den waffen gerufen
worden sind sie hatten den auftrag
insbesondere batterien an der
staatsgrenze vorzunehmen unter anderem
mit gibson mit panzerspähwagen n8 in der
tiefe waren auch kampfpanzer im einsatz
wie unter anderem auch der b 34 85 um
notfalls im verteidigungsfall nach vorne
gezogen zu werden
hauptzweck der eingesetzten kräfte war
es zum einen die staatsgrenze nach außen
zu demonstrieren
auf der anderen seite dem
schutzbedürfnis der bevölkerung
entgegenzukommen
die natürlich verständlicherweise voller
angst war dass die russen wieder auf
österreichische staat gebiet vordringen
konnten
der höchststand der eingesetzten kräfte
des österreichischen bundesheeres betrug
2700 man nach rund zwei monaten am 15
dezember wurde der einsatz für beendet
erklärt und bis 24
dezember kehrten sämtliche verbände und
einheiten mit in ihrer garnisonen zurück
200.000 ungarn sind damals nach
österreich ins benachbarte burgenland
geflohen
über die staatsgrenze und die brücke die
hinter uns ist die brücke von anderer
war das tor der freiheit für ein drittel
dieser ungarischen flüchtlinge also
70.000 ungarische flüchtlinge sind
damals über diese brücke nach österreich
ins burgenland geflogen also die
parallelen zwischen den grenzeinsatz
1956 und denn jetzt aktuell laufenden
grenzeinsatz liegen darin dass es sich
hier um die aufnahme von flüchtlingen
handelt also leute menschen die in not
vor krieg und gewalt flüchten und sich
in sicherheit bringen wollen
parallel ist auch dass sich österreich
1956 wie heute besonders in den
vordergrund getan hat aufgrund
menschlichkeit humanitärer hilfe
nächstenliebe die wird hier gelebt und
auch 56 insbesondere durch die
burgenländer und burgenländerin gelebt
weil 70.000 in sehr sehr kurzer zeit
hier ins burgenland gekommen sind und
daher sind sehr viele aufgenommen worden
auch privat von privaten familien auf
dem burgenländer und burgen erneuern